this week we've got public urinals post
Malone and sneaky buyers we just heard
about the public urinals right now
driving to JK news it's in mm-hmm
we aren't all urinals public no but
they're installing not anymore because
like Paris is such a tourist hotspot no
it looks like a [ __ ] postal drop-off
nope that when we were in Paris I would
be like with my uber driver just looking
outside and then usually when people are
peeing in public right they go toward a
wall this [ __ ]
went toward the street and he would whip
his dick out and pee what you were you
in Paris or San Francisco Paris downtown
LA Yeah right he was peeing toward us
and we're just like what that's nasty
yeah I think it was drunk too though oh
this is so sexy yeah women pee in public
- I see it happening it's not really so
that they should make like a bench oh
yeah this little sexist thing is kind of
over saying that well not for that
reason like women wanted people like to
know it's the opposite where it's like
why are we conforming our area just
because men can't control themselves I
agree with that I do with that position
where it's like you never really see
girls peeing all over the place I know
unless it's at a college town like I
don't see it every time and when I walk
into downtown looking up alleyway I
never got [ __ ] girls peeing here
again I know it's a guy's opinion yeah
so I feel like if girls can do it how
come guys can't and why do we have to
make it convenient for guys what the
hell are you talking about first of all
and secondly yeah right
so here's my thing listen let's wait
where's yours
women could do it you would do it too if
you could like be in the woods and then
suddenly you want to go to the bathroom
and there's nowhere to go I do do the in
the what is different like let's carry
this into into reality now you're back
in civilization okay and you know that
you can do this anywhere and you got to
go to the bathroom somewhere bathroom
you're damn straight you would if you
had the equipment to do it you watchin
though the key word is civilization like
you're supposed to be civil oh yeah I'll
give you a [ __ ] and someone's not
that's pretty cool that's really cool
these ones you're like but look how I it
looks so this is supposed to be like
eco-friendly there's a flower pot on top
of it and it supports our jus you're
surprised that's one - you're surprised
by the pits around the urinal and we
look at it and go yeah looks like a
urinal yeah oh yeah you have to walk you
feel like wade through some stuff to get
to the urinal almost every year I've
ever used at the airport or whatever
it's [ __ ] piss all over the place I
don't know why it splashes on the walls
on the back it's everywhere no idea and
I'm not trying to start anything
political but when the people make that
all gender bathrooms they've gotten so
disgusting because of boys a hundred
percent they're so disgusting to space
the bathrooms are filthy because of
dudes no YouTube space has oh they
changed it that's right remember and now
it's all genders and now the bathrooms
are friggin I haven't been and the girls
probably like give us our bathrooms back
I began to I've been the old man well
gender whatever bathroom that I went to
when we went for Tim's roast that was
the first time I ever saw that I was
like why are the boys in here yeah what
we'll see because the thing is is like
it's not even a transition coz because
trans have been going to the bathroom in
this the bathroom they want forever but
now it's like the regular straight dudes
going in the same bathroom and peeing
everywhere because they don't I guess
they can't aim their dicks right I don't
Stan how come the pee goes everywhere I
don't know either they leave the toilet
seat down and they pee all over the
toilet seat if your check and you went
well if you were born a woman and you
identify now as a man you better be
[ __ ] sloppy on that toilet well you
are not a man
so I have to teach like is that what I
have to do now that I have a boy that's
right I have to teach him how to like
put good leave it you don't have to girl
they'd do it on their own
oh don't do any just light plastic down
in there and let them figure it out I
don't do it I don't know who does I
don't do that I don't [ __ ] on the toilet
seat I don't piss on the toilet you
don't lay sideways turds on the toilet
seat no recording I get it I get it all
right I did it when I was nine so it
might be all the nine year olds that are
doing that [ __ ] Oh
Isaac's perfect day yeah yeah I
guarantee you're gonna find [ __ ] logs
of [ __ ] in those are known to now
because you know finding a logger [ __ ]
on top of the [ __ ] toys need ashame
each other more because as a girl you
get shamed if you do that kind of [ __ ]
you're like your Ovoo you have a boys do
it on purpose I remember now tapping
into my eight nine year old self
I like pissing on the handle I like
pissing on the red pissing on the sea
yeah yeah yeah like doing speeches I
don't do that [ __ ] tonight you're like I
used to piss on the door handle just
because yes this all gender law is a war
against women it is I I agree
you never did that you never [ __ ]
touched those handles now I've never
touched the public hand I put it with my
foot too but I'm just like in elementary
school all that I [ __ ] pissed in
circles all kinds but then the older I
got I was like oh I'm not gonna do that
anymore I'm just gonna pee on the seat
civilized yeah I mean I agree with Joe
as a kid I did but like when you go to
the Staples Center there's not very many
kids around and I should just [ __ ]
yeah so it's adults that are doing it
and I don't know no cuz they drink a
drunk yeah maybe that's why it works you
back to Kia
yeah but when I see poop on the [ __ ]
handle you uh yeah I'm like how do you
miss that
I think that's deliberate or poorly all
right
do guys are disgusting dude Venice Beach
bathrooms dad it's like walking into Mad
Max - yeah it's like holy [ __ ] yeah you
see that toilet seat cover right that
wax paper why is the whole stack on the
floor soaked in pee yeah kids [ __ ]
around
it's good yeah man why do you do that
like the spared like toilet roll -
that's soaked in piss yeah it's in the
middle of the bowl - because they want
you to have that reaction they want to
pee all over the [ __ ] toilet rolls
you understand oh yeah nine year old
nine year old pissed on everything tell
me it's a type of art like graffiti then
I can understand you know I'm saying
it's like it's like it's shitty
is there a Banksy out there of public
restroom who's like yeah you've seen my
work yeah yeah it's like Oh what you're
talking about the toilet paper thing you
know you reached for a spare toilet
paper is that oh yeah that was that's
one of my pieces
he's called [ __ ] see all right for a
night story you guys know who post
Malone is barely I haven't really kept
up with all these rappers but I know
he's a rapper yeah me too
you know this song go they say he's
probably out of the new guys he's
probably the best ones right now what my
tongue that's what they say my young
friends tell me is that seeing rappers
Faldo my young mouth yeah so he recently
surpassed Michael Jackson's Thriller
with the most weeks in the top ten Wow
R&B albums chart which has been held by
Michael Jackson for the past 34 it's
[ __ ] in strollers R&B in hip hop I
thought it was pop bang they put him in
R&B in hip hop I thought the same thing
- it was hot I don't know but yeah post
Malone's 2016 album called stony is the
one that surpassed oh wow
and then he also broke some records - he
did oh he beat a Beatles record back in
May when nine songs from his
chart-topping album beer bongs and
Bentley's nabbed 20 positions on the
Billboard Hot 100 decibels killing it
and I don't even know about it I'm
[ __ ] old
you heard his song though I'll play a
little clip one of his songs that's
really popular Pandora stations and like
Google stations yeah I'm too lazy to
turn on my phone for that I just it goes
straight to the radio yeah so he's
always on the radio every yeah except
for a rock station so if you listen to
pop hip-hop or any of those stations
he's on Oh see it when I do listen to
the radio it's jack FM which is like
old-school [ __ ] yeah FM on - yeah yeah
same dude I'm with you cuz when I was
reading this article I'm like what but
you heard a song before though right you
know no you you gotta you you know I
played this one and then I was just like
yeah whoa if you if you worked out at
barbell you hear all this although
that's that's how I stay connected
because they know like I Travis Scott
and like okay there's all these people
but I don't really know who they are
practice to stay in the loop because of
shopping at the mall like the songs to
play it in the stores but then now I do
all the online shopping and you know
what I do to just know what's going on I
just go to Apple music and then I go
like um new this week yeah I knew this
week and I just let it play through this
you know what the treatment and this
youtuber got top this with this
yesterday or a couple days ago Gabi you
know the gallery yeah yeah [ __ ] first
and second on top ten iTunes
oh she released two singles yeah top one
end too late she did a lot of promo for
it and she came out with a huge music
video for it oh so
and making but tuned and choreograph the
dance for that oh so she they're homies
yeah she like singing legitly as a
parody no no she's actually really good
oh cool like her first single that came
out I was really impressed cuz most
youtubers I'm like that's that's true
okay yeah it was actually well the first
I haven't listened to the new ones but
her first one I actually tweeted her
because I was so impressed
I mean she's up there with all the top
people that's dull it's crazy yeah um
this dude post Malone he's friends with
Ethan from h3 they hang out on like
there they're on the podcast together
that's how I was like I didn't know he
was a white Jewish dude I when I heard
his music I thought he was black the
whole time
cuz I mean he sounds black you know I
mean like oh yeah like little Dickie
like I love did he do I love it when I
first watched that one music video that
went viral I thought those were just
both actors yeah I did not cuz it was
like he looks like someone from like
Lonely Island yeah and I like what he
talks about yeah say that money worthy
drug look say that money say that my
know he makes it cool to kind of like
save money yeah Oh save that money is he
Jewish - I think did he plays into that
stereotype yeah that's fine so he's like
like like the responsible rapper yeah
rapping about curfew
there's one where he does a thing with
Snoop Dogg and he like they're both
cartoons and he's like pointing out a
business plan for Snoop Dogg and like
look at how you don't you have a lack of
Jewish rappers out there and I think
this could fill a niche if we've had
like so it's all in a rap this is the
funny guy right yeah yeah great yeah he
did that one where he switched bodies
with Chris Brown yeah I was a girl you
know it was really good and that was a
popular song - yeah that was like on the
radio and [ __ ] yeah I think he was
comedy first right yeah that's how
there's always comedians in his music
videos all the time mm-hmm
like Sarah Silverman that kind of Lonely
Island
now those parody rapping and you're not
really good I love that lonely ion throw
it on the ground one that's
lover is my jam dude oh yeah my waters
good [ __ ] love mother mother lover
don't you feel uncomfortable because of
the mom [ __ ] [ __ ] your mom sold on
the grounds the one where it's like it's
like go it's your dad what dad is not a
phone it's [ __ ] great
alright for our last story
there's the six-year-old girl named
Caitlin who bought three hundred and
fifty dollars worth of toys on her mom's
Amazon account oh I saw that went viral
so her mom said that she could buy a
Barbie for her birthday
and so she like lets her go on the
Amazon account and like order this
Barbie and then the girls like I just
want to see where the delivery is and
let me shoot she's like let me login one
more time to see like where it's at and
make sure it's gonna get here on time
and this girl ends up ordering $350
worth of stuff a lot of moms amazonica
Mart know until until this delivery day
right so the till Christmas day okay so
this tweet went viral it says my bad
hundred dollars well they reported a 350
yeah I thought it was 350 I don't know
but the tweet says three hundred worth
of toys without my aunt and uncle
knowing this is a picture of how
everyone found out and then if you zoom
in you see her dance
he's like food you dude she didn't girl
it scared of her dad right why would
they let her go like you should order it
that's so weird I'm like Isaac's 10
years old and I don't even let go
they're like you definitely haven't
talked out a Barbie I'm there Barbie but
not click add to order and then check
the tracking to check the tracking is
what Trish them so they were watching
her when she was ordering the Barbie
yeah but then when she tricked them by
being like can I just log in one more
time and check on the order she's smart
that's super smart her parents are dumb
keep an eye on this girl she's gonna
she's going places shitless of my dad I
would never do it I love that reaction
though she's like
did you keep the toys so the update was
that Caitlyn chose to donate all of the
toys to the Children's Hospital where
she stayed for a week when she was a
baby I wanted to give a little joy to
those who aren't well that's so sweet
[ __ ] she got caught yeah Caitlyn got
caught is all that tweet said yeah what
she did get caught by him that they
delivered it right that's what I'm
saying so of course she had to do some
way that's why she couldn't keep all of
it apology tour yeah exactly if she
didn't get caught she'd be freaking yeah
we all know it well I was like well I
mean they could just return it to a
hospital
she made her and an uncle donated to
Children's Hospice would you would you
be mad at that I don't think I could get
mad at that I wouldn't be mad I'd be
like it's my it's my fault
yeah for sure I'd be like I think that's
hilarious
what if you don't even have 300 bucks
good for you though then you'd be pretty
pissed yeah exactly
I'd be pissed on my bank clearly these
privileged parents that's right I'm just
kidding you don't have to be hundred
bucks can't you just return it that's
what I was saying that's true I mean you
wouldn't think it was funny if you
didn't have 300 bucks and they spent 300
bucks yeah you kicked ass right yeah and
most considering most Americans barely
have 1200 bucks
like saved but because they all have
paycheck to paycheck I think a lot of
people identify more they just said most
Americans they can't even spend $400
without like [ __ ] up their financial
world yeah 300 is a lot yeah
400 is a quarter we did this on JK news
we're like 60 or 70% of Americans they
don't have any savings and they're in
the negatives mm-hmm they're living on
credit right well I know I bet those are
the ones that went to college and got
loans and stuff that's why yeah quite
like 70 to 80 percent because so many
people are in know anything about
finance stuff yeah they don't know what
compounding interest they don't teach
you it in school don't know any of that
they do it on purpose
is there a pot down their pockets the
too busy teaching about the French
Revolution
why the [ __ ] are they teaching about the
French Revolution like they should be
teaching about your finances
give me a break I've never used out of
my life ever have you never I really
like I did when I went to Paris really
how I I was at Napoleon's place and I
was like oh yeah this is what happened
but it's because you can recall what you
like this is where what happened let's
hear it
[Laughter]
this is where they revolted against the
[ __ ] Royals and and in chopped off
their heads I don't think the polling
was a part of that that I know but
Napoleon died here separately let's do
it on the side yeah it's [ __ ]
pointless over it yeah but they won't
teach you about finance they don't even
teach you mother you don't want you to
know I know they don't want you to know
train you to be good employees that's
right good cheap and right and make sure
that you need loans and make sure that
you buy cars and that need loans and
then when you need a house you need a
loan yeah you need to rely on somebody
else that's what they teach you
hopefully the government being in debt
it's like modern-day slavery though
because it is if you're in debt let's
say immediately out of college you owe
what's the average now like 80 40
something like that and if you go to a
super prestigious private school it
could be like forty thousand a semesters
so that's four semesters FSTA oh that's
forty thousand semester two semesters
eighty thousand a year
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy and if you go
for four years
that's 120 no 300 and if you can't
afford something you put it on three
hundred twenty thousand for four years
if you can't afford something right you
can take out a loan to buy it oh you use
credit or it's like twelve easy payments
and you pay throughout the year and if
you're going for a doctor or [ __ ]
lawyer or whatever those degrees that's
hundreds of thousands of dollars mm-hmm
that you immediately graduate but
supposedly your career will give you so
much more which is what what what this
is what though you see this is what the
racket is so my buddy pharmacist right
yeah she's like $200,000 in debt or more
now he gets a job sure he gets his
six-figure pay but you know what he says
that most of his friends do
soon as you get that money then you want
to buy a house you want to buy a car you
want to get your life a house that's
what in LA at least $700,000 I'm waiting
how much is a wedding like thirty thirty
but then if your prestigious farm is
seventy seventy right right a car what
$100,000 car is your pharmacist now you
got to keep up well what about you want
to get married
guess what you got to buy a ring but you
have to use the two paychecks or
whatever the [ __ ] it has to be the
diamond worth two of your paycheck so
what it's got a twenty thousand dollar
ring all the memes are dead I give you
all my paychecks boom hey baby I had no
complaints buying that for you no
complaints it's just that the fact that
they control the diamond supply and
artificially inflate the prices of
diamonds that's the [ __ ] that pisses
many diamonds weren't always the the
sign of love it wasn't it's just a very
new marketing you know what Alice now
everyone has it in their head that if
you don't love that person if you don't
give them a diamond it's true
damn some crazy antelope used to just be
a little tiny little Cuba would you all
know that everything gallery right yeah
it was a dowry
no just a little bit little bit didn't
go to the girl I went to their family
yeah good it's like he lost product now
mm-hmm
now how is he gonna make even dad or in
some cultures don't they give it to the
guys family cuz they're like take our
daughter she's worth it yeah cuz then
you gotta you get to take the headache
away from the dad understand that that
the last day I was gonna suck your dick
hard actually it was the same video is
it was the first story you win you had a
such a story arc understand
yeah how's that [ __ ] looking over
there buddy well from the honeymoon to
the dirt can't suck your own dick I know
talking about it I now wish a kid you
could take yoga lessons
[Music]